Let me tell you how miserable my mornings
are without breakfast. I hate everyone, yes
everyone. Even that old lady who took the
last seat on the train. I hate you.
Hey guys Julia here for DNews
Do we need breakfast? Your mom always tells
you to eat your breakfast, but do you really
need to?
A recent study published in Journal of Public
Economics says yes. The researchers found
that schools that provided free breakfast
for their students had better test scores
than those that didn’t. The kids performed
25% better in math, and had similar gains
in other areas like reading.
But this news isn’t entirely new. Breakfast
is heralded as the most important meal of
the day. And science backs this up. There
are loads of studies that show just how important
it is for learning and memory, but it might
not have the weight loss benefits you think.
Anyways, is it breakfast that helps give the
brain a boost? Or is it the type of food you
eat?
I mean, the brain consumes a lot of energy.
Almost 20% of the energy we consume goes to
the brain. Some researchers say that the brain
functions best when there’s 25 grams of
glucose circulating through the bloodstream.
So really, you should keep that as level as
possible- any spike or dip can leave you feeling
off. So maybe eating more frequent smaller
meals throughout the day can help you avoid
a “post lunch crash”.
But is there a way to hack your brain with
food? Is there such a thing as “brain food?”
I was always told to eat a banana before a
test.
Curcumin[CUR-Q-MIN] and Omega 3s seem to be
buzzing around the blogsphere of late. And
there may be some truth to that. According
to a paper published in the National Review
of Neuroscience, these nutrients lessen cognitive
decline in the elderly and improve cognition
in people with brain injuries. You’re typical
sources of this stuff are fish, like salmon,
Flax seeds and walnuts.
Curcumin can be found mostly in tumeric, a
type of spice. Iron and b vitamins help memory
and brain function in women. While diets high
in saturated fats, tend to do the opposite.
Omega threes and other micronutrients seem
to be the heavy hitters of brain food. One
study published in the American Journal of
Clinical Nutrition found that a cocktail of
omega-3s, iron, zinc, folate and vitamins
A, B6, B12 and C, helped kids in Australia
and Indonesia do better on learning and memory
tests.
Another study published in the journal Appetite
by some of the same researchers found that
foods low on the glycemic index are better
for breakfast. The glycemic index rates food
based on how it affects your glucose levels,
or levels of sugar. The study found that yes,
kids memory and cognitive function decline
throughout the morning, but a low GI breakfast
reduced that decline more than a high GI did.
Low GI foods are like fruits and vegetables
or oatmeal. So a good breakfast might be a
bowl of oatmeal with a banana rather than
a bowl of cereal.
So yes, a balanced diet, with fish and fruits
and veggies seems to be good for the brain.
Eating breakfast might keep you perkier in
the morning so you’re more alert to learn
more. And some studies even show that that
old wives tale of chewing gum for a test is
true. Chewing gum increases blood flow to
the brain, which more does all sorts of good
things.
So before a big test, eat a good breakfast,
no not sugary cereals and maybe have a piece
of gum.